[Music]
on this tuesday night
making history at rideau hall inuk
leader mary simon is named canada's
first
indigenous governor general i am honored
humbled and ready who she is and how her
appointment could be a powerful symbol
of reconciliation landmark agreement
the first nation now empowered to make
decisions for indigenous children
in government care frayed nerves as
wildfires spread through british
columbia oh it was terrifying
what's fanning the flames as more people
are ordered out of their homes
and high-speed connection the potential
new railroad between canada's two
biggest provinces
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight
bara nasser good evening glad you're
with us tonight
we begin with the historic appointment
of canada's new governor general
mary simon an e-nuke leader will take
the role as the queen's representative
in canada she will be the first
indigenous governor general
in this country simon began her career
as a journalist then became a diplomat
in 1994 she was named canada's first
ambassador
for circumpolar affairs in 1999 simon
became canada's ambassador to denmark
right now she is a fellow at the arctic
institute of north america
where climate change is a major theme of
her recent work
simon's appointment fills a vacancy left
by julie payet's sudden resignation in
january
and it also comes at a critical moment
for canada's relationship with
indigenous peoples
david aiken has our top story tonight
let me begin by conveying in the
strongest possible terms
that i am honored humbled
and and ready to be canada's first
indigenous governor general the pm's
pick for the country's
30th governor general won near unanimous
approval
notably from indigenous leaders like
natan obed
president of the organization that
speaks for the country's 65 thousand
inuit
i couldn't be happier with this election
also just as in enoch to
to hear somebody speaking in institute
and to be given this particular role
which is such a meaningful role in
this particular parliamentary democracy
obed's organization was one of a chorus
of indigenous groups to praise mary
simon's appointment
she's representing all of canada and i
know that she'll be able to do an
excellent job um you know in
representing all of
all of canada simon who will turn 74 in
august
was born in kujuwak in northern quebec
as a girl
she attended a federal day school where
instruction was
explicitly english only my bilingualism
is innoctitude and english however based
on my
experience growing up in quebec i was
denied
the chance to learn french during my
time
in the federal government day schools
her inability to speak french has
already raised eyebrows in quebec
but simon has vowed to learn french and
do business at rideau hall
in both official languages but it is her
indigeneity
the fact that she is an inuk woman that
makes her appointment
historic and meaningful to many there
are
very important responsibilities
associated with my role that will help
the working relationship of canadians
and indigenous people
she understands that this is a very
difficult time in this this
country and that she has a healing role
to play
and she's ready to do it now one of
simon's first
major official acts could be to consider
a request from prime minister trudeau
to dissolve parliament and hold an
election later this summer
now if trudeau did that he would be
breaking canada's fixed date election
law
would simon let him do that the two of
them say the topic never came up
vara david aiken in ottawa thank you
david
a major rail announcement today also
fueling speculation of a federal
election
this year the trudeau liberals revealed
plans for a high frequency rail line
between toronto
and quebec city the trains could hit
speeds up to 200 kilometers an hour
and cut travel time by 25 percent
the rail corridor is designed to be more
sustainable with 90 percent of the
service running on electricity
it should be up and running by 2030 at a
cost of six
to 12 billion dollars that is a welcome
change in the well-traveled region but
as michael couture reports
it doesn't exactly help everyone
a trained platform is not a campaign
platform but it may as well have been
for four high-profile liberals
announcing the high-profile
rail project the new train line will be
high frequency rail
not high speed we discovered that the
increased incremental increase in speed
is not really
going to offer the most efficiency when
you look at the cost and the time span
but it would make the trip between
quebec city and toronto
90 minutes shorter popular politically
along a route the liberals would love to
make red
the proposed hfr network will have stops
at quebec city's airport
and tuaregia on the way to montreal some
existing rails will be used but the
trains will run
on mostly new tracks with two new stops
just outside of toronto it's one of the
busiest rail corridors of the country
but
missing from the map is windsor ontario
which
is normally part of that commuter
conversation
this obviously leads out a very high
density well-traveled
portion of that region and
that's a question i think the government
should answer
it's a big promise that should be
popular with key voting blocks
cue that election speculation
an election has nothing to do with
something like this says innovation
minister francois philip champang
but the project could be a boon for
battlegrounds in quebec city
and tuaregal where the liberals are
hoping to maintain
or even pick up seats in the next
election there's a really good
opportunity
for the liberal government to gain back
a seat they haven't held a seat in
prager
since 1984. the project will have to go
through
environmental impact assessments and
consultations with indigenous
communities
before the request for proposal process
can begin this fall
which could be in the middle of a
federal
election farah michael couture
in ottawa thank you mike a historic
agreement has been signed today between
the kausas first nation the province of
saskatchewan
and the federal government it gives the
nation jurisdiction over its own
child welfare system many advocates say
canada's child welfare system has become
the new proxy for
residential schools thousands of
indigenous children
are currently in care according to
census data from 2016
more than 52 percent of all children in
foster care under the age of 15
were indigenous that's nationally in
saskatchewan the number is even higher
in 2019 80 percent of children in foster
care
were indigenous as heather urex west
explains the kausas first nation hopes
this agreement
will help change that
it's been almost two weeks since the
kawasa's first nation
shared its unimaginable heartbreak with
the rest of the country
the flags here mark as many as 751
previously unmarked graves many believed
to belong to children who died while
attending
residential school it is shameful
that here in cowissas and across the
country
children died because of the policy
of residential schools residential
schools began a legacy of trauma many
families have passed
down through generations today thousands
of indigenous children are taken
into the child welfare system instead
the kawasa's first nation lost
jurisdiction over these kids back in
1951
but a landmark agreement signed tuesday
gives
that power back this is an important
step forward
and at the end of the day it'll mean
fewer children and youth
in care and across the country
we are working with other first nations
to reach similar agreements
the new child welfare legislation was
made possible by canada's
landmark bill c-92 which empowers
indigenous communities to reclaim
jurisdiction the mio pima tissuan act
gives the nation the right to make
decisions over the estimated 165
kawasa's children currently in
government care
the end goal is one day there will be no
children in care
i'm 39 years old i hope that happens in
my lifetime
but causes we have a lot of work to do
the key is whether or not the federal
government is going to provide the
resources that will be
needed in to ensure that all the
children receive full benefit from that
legislation
cindy blackstock says she's skeptical
having spent
years in court with the federal
government fighting to get equitable
funding for first nations children in
care
across the country indigenous
communities say it's time
progress is made we have said loudly
that our first nations
must take the responsibility to take
care
of our own children we are developing
our own child well-being laws
and it's time for the government to get
out of the way
kawasa's first nation is hoping for
roughly 40 million dollars annually to
operate a lodge to help keep families
together
in the hope of healing trauma that has
spawned generations
heather urex west global news calgary
now to british columbia where there is
no rest for fire crews on the front line
they're dealing with dozens of new
wildfires after a series of lightning
storms struck parts of the province
there are now more than 200 wildfires
actively burning in bc
the majority of them about 70 percent
are believed to be caused by lightning
more than 60 fires are burning out of
control 13 are considered
fires of note meaning they pose a
potential risk
and threat to public safety robin gill
reports on the communities on edge and
under threat from the fast moving fires
once again fire crews in british
columbia rush to save a neighborhood
this time it's in the southern okanagan
between asoyus and oliver
and once again homeowners are sent into
survival mode
grab the kids grabbed the pets put them
all in the truck and by then the fire
was already spreading really quickly
48 new fires in just 24 hours more than
70 percent of these caused by lightning
compared to the seasonal average
we are significantly higher in terms of
number of fires and hectares burned
for the 5 10 15 20 and 25 year average
the federal government is deploying
military muscle helicopters and
personnel
to help move equipment and if need be
get people out of fire zones
and the fires aren't showing any sign of
slowing in the durham lake area
ranchers stayed behind to save their
farms and livestock
even though there was an evacuation
order when you have
your cattle that you look after all year
up there and they are
threatened and you can't get in there to
to get them um it's pretty emotional
it's been a very stressful spring period
because we've had
we've had the driest spring we've had in
there they're saying in the hundred
hundred year category back in oliver
residents are allowed to return after
just a few hours
we're just so relieved and that our
houses were all standing and they're
okay because they really did come very
very close
the stress and exhaustion are palpable
in a province that's only in the
beginning phase
of fire season robin gill global news
vancouver
we're getting a better sense tonight at
the devastating impacts of last week's
record-breaking heat wave in bc
according to new data from the bc
coroner service
the number of sudden deaths reported
last week was nearly
quadruple what's usually seen in that
same time period
in the previous five years the number of
deaths reported between june 25th
and july 1st ranged between 179
and 232 in that same week this year
there were 777. bc's coroner service
says it's still too early to confirm the
cause of death
though the chief coroner says it's
believed heat was a significant
contributing factor the same heat wave
that has blasted bc is causing
major problems for farmers on the
prairies
one community in manitoba says the
situation is so severe
it's declared a state of emergency the
rural municipality of saint laurent says
it's received very little rain farmers
dugouts are running dry
and it's not only that they're also
dealing with a major grasshopper
infestation
they're just destroying the fields and
so now there's a feed issue for the
livestock
as well as a water issue so it's become
to a point where farmers are actually
thinking of selling their livestock
selling the farm the manitoba government
says it has programs and services
available to help farmers manage
in florida the body of one of the
missing canadians in the champlain
towers condo collapse
was pulled from the mountain of debris
today global affairs canada confirmed
the recovery of the person's remains
the victim's identity has not been
officially made public
three other canadians are among the more
than 100 people still unaccounted for
at least 70 of the missing were
confirmed to be in the 12-story tower
when it crumbled early june 24th
according to the miami-dade county mayor
the demolition of the remaining
structure sunday night has allowed
search crews
better access to dig through the rubble
from the initial collapse
and to recover more bodies the confirmed
death toll now stands
at 36. stanley cup fever rises in
montreal
coming out the crucial game that had
habs fans on the edge
of their seats
for soccer fans in montreal some
disappointing news
the city announced it has officially
withdrawn its bid to host some of the
2026 fifa world cup
the city says it made the decision after
the quebec government withdrew financial
support
the 2026 world cup is set to be jointly
hosted
by the u.s canada and mexico edmonton
and toronto are now the only canadian
cities
under consideration jet setting during
the pandemic
ahead where the private planes regularly
used by some prominent canadians
touched down while the rest of us stayed
at home
throughout the kovit 19 pandemic the
federal government has asked canadians
to stay home
and avoid all non-essential travel
outside of the country
testing requirements and quarantine
measures made it even difficult to try
and fly away
but many private jets have been going to
and from
sunshine destinations even while
canadian airlines suspended flights
to and from the caribbean and some
passengers
may have been legally able to skip out
on staying in a quarantine hotel
as redmond shannon reports jets
regularly used by some very
high profile names in the past have been
racking up the air miles
the bombardier jet regularly used by
cirque du soleil founder gila liberty
touches down in tahiti last fall but
it's another two-hour flight to his
private island and his resort
that can be rented by guests data on
flight tracking website adsb exchange
shows the bombardier jet made five more
trips to tahiti
over the coldest months of the pandemic
with extended stays in hawaii too
the data does not say who was on each
flight
[Music]
he's not the only canadian who flies in
style
on a distinctive jet the air drake
boeing 767 made
for caribbean trips during the pandemic
including one flight from hamilton
ontario
while the province was under a
stay-at-home order since march 2020 the
federal government has urged canadians
to avoid
non-essential travel but the definition
of essential
is left up to the individual the
government in describing us
as only doing essential travel never
gave any guidelines as to what essential
was
on one occasion this year drake was
reportedly shooting
a music video in the bahamas from
february until monday this week
even vaccinated passengers flying into
canada were obligated
to pre-book three nights in a government
quarantine hotel
upon arrival drake's publicist declined
to answer questions about who was on the
flights and whether they
ever checked in to a quarantine hotel a
spokesperson for
liberte wouldn't comment on his travels
but said gee
and all guests on the plane scrupulously
respected
sanitary measures and quarantines but
unlike commercial passengers
it's possible they and many other
private jet users
relied on rapid molecular test services
getting their negative covert results
before they could even
check into a hotel and allowing them to
quarantine entirely at home
there might have been a few instances
where after completing that cbsa test
kit they received the result in a timely
fashion and they
they left as as you would and as was
directed
canadian aircraft charter companies did
not answer global news questions about
whether they
offered this service many of their jets
have made
round trips to the caribbean earlier
this year even while commercial canadian
airlines agreed to suspend
direct flights to the region aircraft
owned by companies like irving oil
transport and
nova scotia-based cffi ventures have
flown to canada from the u.s this year
via mandatory stops in toronto or
montreal
where the quarantine hotels are located
but the planes
then quickly flew on to smaller canadian
airports
cfi said its fleet is operated in
accordance with all guidelines
rules and laws irving oil did not
respond to a request for comment
redmond shannon global news london
turning anger into something good why
this 12 year old mikma boy walked 200
kilometers
in six days
a 12 year old indigenous boy in nova
scotia has ended a
long emotional journey landon tony
wrapped up a walk in memory of survivors
and victims of residential schools
and it resonated as ross lord reports
the simple gesture
struck a real cord with canadians
after walking more than 200 kilometers
in only six days
landon tony sprints across the finish
line
triumphant in his grueling walk called
landon's journey of awareness
a simple but trying active endurance
that's spreading
pride very worth it the walk
everything just the reaction of the
people when i got here
it was awesome heady stuff for a boy who
just turned 12 years old
landon's mother who walked beside him
says he's been advocating for years
for more awareness of indigenous culture
she hopes the powerful symbolism
of an indigenous child walking for
empowerment is something all canadians
can support
he could have been a residential
child a few generations ago
and hopefully be more open-minded
to educating themselves on the hidden
truths
[Applause]
landon's journey passed through several
first nations communities
with a growing number of supporters
cheering him on
yeah landon
an online fundraiser has topped 30
thousand dollars
how it's spent will be determined at a
later date after a review of those most
in need
i hope after this a lot of people open
their eyes and get educated
on everything that has happened to our
people especially with the residential
schools
landon says he's humbled by the
outpouring of support and generosity
he says he plans to make more efforts to
bring about positive change
every single year i'm going to be doing
something like this
ross lord global news
a young boy with hope for a brighter
future for all of us
that is global national for this tuesday
i'm farah nasser thank you so much for
spending part of your evening with us
tonight's your canada is caddy lake in
southeastern manitoba
until tomorrow take care of yourselves
and each other